foreign
[Music]
I wanted this to be the scariest
depiction of Dracula ever there's
something potent about that mythology
everyone knows fear and I think Dracula
represents that this chapter of Bram
Stoker's Dracula hasn't been told
what actually happened on the ship that
transported Dracula from the port of
Varna to England
by itself just fascinating
Dracula is trying to find more people
more blood a better place to feed this
looks like a bite what better place than
the huge city of London ship
everywhere
it's monster time when the lights go ill
alien style story set on the ocean in
1897 and with Dracula instead of the
alien monster it was just all the
elements were really exciting
there's no way off this ship and that
evil is lurking right there we've yet to
experience this extreme emotion of fear
but safely
oh my God have mercy on us all he's the
perfect monster you look at the images
and it's just magic man it's magic
it's Dracula and I want to kill the
cusset thing
the Demeter
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
contents are known
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's comments he's a doctor
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival in London
let me show you the ship
we don't come with like this to give the
use clear
to me is a fine belt No Doubt
[Applause]
something ripped about the animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
laughs
[Music]
in night it swings our blood he is here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
you see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]